dès l'ouverture du président barack
obama à l'endroit du régime cubain a
fait grimper le nombre d'américains qui
visitent l'île
mais comme ils ne peuvent pas faire du
tourisme comme tels ces voyageurs
contourne ouvertement la loi américaine
sur les sanctions économiques qui sont
imposées à cuba alors qui sont-ils
pourquoi serait-il dans l'île des castro
notre envoyé spécial jean michel
leprince
on a rencontré quelques-uns ils sont
discrets et encore peu nombreux ils ont
leur hôtel de prédilection le
prestigieux national mémoire de cuba et
non loin du capitole petit washington
tropicales des années 50
l'hôtel saratoga vous ne le verrez pas
sur les plages ce ne sont pas des
touristes
la loi américaine interdit aux
américains de faire du tourisme à cuba
sanctions oblige alors ce que font ces
américains c'est légalement des échanges
culturels ou sportifs ou religieux obama
et house castro ont incité deux cent
mille américains à venir en 2015 goûter
au fruit défendu
un record
geo darger est née à cuba que ses
parents ont quitté en 1976 il à renouer
avec ses racines il ya 15 ans en faisant
visiter l'île
à quelques rares américains disons
désobéissance
chuck hayes c'est du sérieux au
programme ce matin l' architecture
cullers puis ce groupe d'une dizaine
d'amis du texas rend visite à une
famille cubaine dans son logement de
style art déco inchangé depuis la
révolution
quoi de plus piquant pour ces américains
que ce restaurant au nom russe dans
l'envié qui leur permet de se replonger
dans l'époque de la guerre froide quand
lille vivait sous la protection du grand
frère soviétique nostalgie l'histoire
pèse lourd à cuba nulle part ailleurs
plus qu'à l'hôtel national le gardien de
ce musée vivant c'est l'ancien général
d'armée antonio martins
c'est la grande majorité des clients de
l'hôtel et américaines
ils viennent revivre ici les folles
années 30 et 40 celle des casinos du jeu
de la production crime organisé du feu
n'avait pas fui au zoo majerle en ski
avant de goûter au mojito de la mafia
les états
evènement c'est le national des acteurs
d'hollywood
les artistes et des centaines de chefs
d'état qui hante encore les murs du
fameux bar de l'histoire
qui ça
ça
je suis si nos faux touristes se disent
que surpris et ravis par ce qu'ils ont
vu à la vanille et il se félicite d'être
venu avant le grand débarquement
redouter de leurs compatriotes invasion
pas encore tout juste l'avant garde
nationale
mais que ce soit une invasion
constructive positive et attirante
c'est le souhait du général et high end
ou les